FACE-OFF IS TOEITH
YANDLE.
THE REIGNING IRON MAN IN THE
NATIONAL
BIG CHANCE FOR HAMILTON.
ON THE PUCK WRISTER OFF
THE CROSSBAR.
LOOK AT THE PUCK A
SHOT.
LOOKING FOR A HISCHIER.
FLYERS BREAK UP THE PASS.
SHORTHANDED.
AN OPPORTUNITY HERE.
LAUGHTON TRYIN TOUGH PLAY BECAU.
HE'S A
TWO OPPORTUNITIES.
>> Steve: JOHNSSON AGAIN,
SHOOTING.
HEHE INITIAL SAVE.
JOHNSSON JUST SHOT IT OFF THE
NET. KNOCKED TO
THE ICE
AFTER A SPIRITED BOUT ARE BACK
TO THEIR RESPECTIVE SLOT.
TRYING TO PULL THE TRIGGER O
IN TIME TO PICK THAT PUCK UP AND
MAKE A GGET IT ONDROP.
FARABEE
THE FLYERS HAVE SHORTHANDED
GAMES IN THE
HISCHIER PATIENTLY DROPS IT
BACK. A TWISTED WRISTER, AS
THEY
TIPPING ON NET.
>> Steve: THEY CUT INET.
THEY CHIP IT, KEEP THINGS ALIVE.
RIGHT HERE DEV CENTER.
ON THE  SHOT.
BLOCKED BY LAST LOOK
AS COUTURIER FROM HIS RIGHT
SKATE TO HIS  AROUND
THE DEVILS' NET.
>> Steve: JOHNSSON JUST RIGHT A
FLYERS WERE REALLY APPLYING ALL
HAMILTON PLAYS IT ACROSS,  AROU.
BLOCKED.
DEVILS,
HE IN FRONT.
JOHNSSON GOES FOR THE EMPTY NET
AGAINST THIS